[Music]
and taking a sharp turn the moment
you've all been waiting for
it is time for our jeopardy warm-up we
get to see which of our contestants
knows the most about las vegas our
contestants tonight
ted florindo christian cazarez
and brian loftus and you know of course
we're going to give you a clue and again
whoever wins tonight gets deemed
a title that probably doesn't mean much
to you but we'll call him the smartest
anchor
all right let's get started contestants
here is tonight's
question who was the only southern
nevadan swimmer
to medal in the olympic games oh boy
15 seconds probably less hmm
john creech kind of looks like an
olympia five seconds
let's punctuate these answers
okay going from right to left ted
florindo
uh who is somebody i can't remember ah
a gentleman right gentlemen right kind
of a poor effort
how about you christian all right i'm
gonna go for
ted florence beth lorendo all right
brian my first question is where's
john's tie yeah
and then here's my actual answer yes oh
wow
really good guess very creative very
close so why don't you build this person
hey
yes cody miller it was indeed connor
fields
is an olympian from las vegas so that
was
much more educated than your competitors
i went with the wrong sport
i went bmx yeah you're you were way off
there when i went on land this is pool
it was cool yeah i think cody miller
actually took john's tie in his jacket
too you know what
it's fourth of july weekend it's
independent you're ready
i'm actually surprised john's wearing a
shirt right now okay let's
pump the brakes hey how many push-ups do
you think john can do in a row
one thousand this is gonna operate
thousands push-ups
yeah i got some cake for you can we give
you some cake
you can eat some cake you can't eat some
cakes this has been great
the answer is cody miller hold on who's
the better athlete john treats your cody
miller
i promise you it's cody miller hold on
are you bringing this
[Music]
epervious unum you can join us at
8newsnow.com along with facebook
and twitter be sure to watch news now at
11.
happy 4th july